even though i love my girlfriend my ex
blank is the better blank
you have to make it make sense just say
what you really mean
i know you want to say it full
free gosh
[Music]
welcome to relationship goals i'm phil
johnson your host and i'm with one two
funny this guy is gonna be the judge
jury and executioner relationship goals
is a tournament where coppers go head to
head to see who's got the most solid
couple if they win this they go to the
semi-final if they win at the semi-final
they go to the final and if they win the
final
jordan everybody
even though this money you know
but more importantly as my judges
demonstrated they win 100 free fire away
pizzas
and whoever wins just know about me and
them with friends from time you go i'm
saying let's hope
and we are back actually again let's see
what this week let's see what happens
this week
do you think you're gonna win yeah we're
all about the bag man
bone witness it's all about this money
okay don't forget the money welcome back
to the semi-final of relationship goals
so for round one
we're gonna ask your boyfriend some
questions and make them fill in the
blanks
so ladies could you return to the
soundproof room please and put on them z
technology headphones
alright so for round one question one i
used to be more enthusiastic about blank
with him than i am now so you imagine
your girlfriend saying this
i'm gonna go with jahin first
about
my love
my affection
okay
but so she used to be more enthusiastic
about her love for you so she's she's
not as affectionate as she used to be
yeah
is that in the bedroom or is that just
no outside the bedroom because he's in
the bedroom everything's calm
everything's closed everybody's calm i
like everything to be wild in the
bedroom with my girlfriend but if you
like it calm that's that's on you cool
harms i'm gonna repeat the question i
used to be more enthusiastic about blank
than i am now when we first met i know
that like the first thing like for both
of us because we that's what um that's
our similar interest in it so fashion
she [ __ ] in my fashion like before
like earlier but like
and now she's just saying you've got
dead drips i was very stressed
like she's just hated maybe like that's
maybe a few things that we argue about
you argue about who dresses better wow
you love clothes
no i'm dressing better today no i'm
dressing better today who is the best
dressed out of this whole show all the
time let us know in the comments guys
is it mr 645 over here
or is it theo johnson who knows it
definitely ate the contestants
for question two
i'm only willing for his blank without
that i'd be gone i'm gonna go to you
first harms this time
basically
we spoke about her ex or dean
and she told me the main reason why she
didn't like him and what she likes me
for was loyalty like he wasn't loyal
okay that's what i would say so she's
only with you for your loyalty
without that she's gone
i guess all right cool
i would say
for my achievement
so you're saying your girlfriend's with
you because you're driven yeah because
you strive for better things every day
yeah okay i'm only with him for his
ambition without that i'll be gone
ambition your ambition will be fine all
right cool
is priceless it's certain in your dreams
now i need you like to listen carefully
because i'm sure this this question is
going to take you 10 years to get even
though i love my girlfriend
my ex is blank is the better
blank
blank man started itching his face
[Music]
um i'm gonna need an answer from you
first this time i think what i stated
last week like attitude so
my ex was nicer than
okay all right even though i love my
girlfriend my ex
blank is the better blank so it has to
go like that you have to make sense of
that sentence yeah
you have to make it make sense
come on i'm gonna give you a five count
to say what you really mean
how do you wanna say it four
three
two one don't be shy gosh
yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
i am kill me now
no way
i could feel him thinking it and i could
see him trying to be politically correct
good work that you squeezed out of him
you know
the toothpaste is done but you have to
oh
yes you'd say
cheeky bugger
okay jahen can we have an answer please
um my ex is thickness
my girls got better and yeah that's for
sure
he said he said it in italics
brilliant can we get the ladies back
please
for that round we asked your boys some
interesting questions and
let's just say they gave some
interesting answers
so for question one i used to be way
more enthusiastic about blank with him
than i am now okay ayanna stop looking
at him look at us please could we have
an answer please what would you say
i'm saying
like
what he wears
is that a bag
like his was like fashion so you used to
be more enthusiastic about his fashion
but now he's letting himself go a little
bit because his drip's a bit dead yeah
it's a bit drought
yeah
there's a drought in the drip
i think i will say the same
dress sense as well not dresses but
um
south care yeah damn he looks pretty
sharp to me though no it's cute it's so
cute but like always to me not only when
you have something to do yourself hey so
when is this he just lets himself go
until he until we got a show out for
certain you're saying when you get
someone just wipes off that hairline
that right there was a violation i
wouldn't have it you said personal
appearance oh yena you said drip i can
now confirm used to are correct
well done yeah he actually said
but now since you've been speaking about
power with your bedroom you're not as
affectionate anymore that's what he said
don't shoot the messenger i'm just
saying anyway question
two i'm only with him for his blank
without that i'd be gone
um
mayo you can answer first this time what
are you only willing for without that
and you'll be gone we've established it
ain't hairline
i'm gonna have to give you the five
count because you're taking how long so
i'm only losing four
yeah
you have to fill in the blanks we've
been doing this now this is this is
round two
it's love
oh
oh
that is so oh
bloody boring oh she's already waiting
for his love ayanna
i feel like i mean now i'm on why
because my opposite
oh what's yours with you're only waiting
for his hate for his hate no
because
wait wait what what did you just
say i didn't i said i don't know
no seriously though
money yeah
wow she said yeah fast
and i can now
confirm
that both of y'all
passed with flight now you didn't you
know you
atrocious
was like yeah it was very poor i'm very
disappointed in all of you frog legs
over here said his success slash
ambition basically said if he was a
failure you know you'd be out here just
you know jean francis um and
over here uh he said loyalty
yeah so that's the key mate if i was you
she's only lured to your money
skate along go get yourself some new
pumpkin okay so for question three we
asked your boyfriends this
even though i love my girlfriend
my ex is blank is the better blank
please listen to the love
keyword is love here today girls because
i know you like don't listen to keywords
you only listen to the bad stuff so key
word is even though he loves you
his x's blank is the better blank
yeah i know this is funny because in
this sentence just for the boys at home
because the girls know this but the boys
don't
even know i'm gonna say even though he
loves you a thousand times they're not
gonna hear it they're not going to hear
love selective hearing there is no there
is no love in this sentence to the girls
they're just going to hear my exes is
the better yeah that's all right cool
what do you think he answered what do
you think jack answered
um
the fact that the fact that she's more
thick than me
bomber
is
is she more thick yeah it says she's got
that fit comes yeah thick with three c's
in it yeah
yeah
she keeps smelling like the thicknesses
her thickness
thickness is
a piece of her flesh just got caught up
her nose
that's how thick she is she's everywhere
she
she's just so thicky thick okay cool um
i'm gonna say like
more affectionate more kinder
his ex was more
yeah kinder yeah yeah yeah
totally
anyways i'll i'll do the favors
well i'd like to uh uh yeah you're
laughing mate because you know you got
your question right you was correct his
ex does have the thickums um
show me a picture after though i'm
trying to see this
i thought you could have done this
i trust you now go on uh and um yeah
your boyfriend we had to kind of squeeze
it out of him no homo he said yes
that's why we was laughing yeah just
like that he said that
what his head was vibrating i don't mean
it
um so all you have to do ayanna is
sometimes you just have to like do some
kegel exercises sometimes you just
actually said that just quit a bit you
know i didn't you know
you need this sometimes
if you just start doing it if you start
doing your squats you don't quit a bit
you know do them kegel exercises i'm
sure you'll be back to
you know i'm saying normality in no time
so we can now reveal that yeah he said
nash
he was wrong
he said vick him he was right you get
the point the overall points for this
round
is one oh well done guys
unlike her
okay round two
[Music]
if we were animals my boyfriend would be
a blank in the bedroom
sorry
i don't know a lion
okay is that how you feeling yeah yeah
so he just jumps on you and tears you
apart yeah
raw what about you you know
apparently
no no i've got this i think
i think he'd be like a sloth
a sloth okay
no clock can i explain animals can i
just explain why he's he's he's quite um
he's not
he's very
it the animal is so useless
what does it do bro it just swings and
just an animal is so useful that's a bad
goodness you know what
okay cool
if my boyfriend blanks again
i'll be gone
oh jenna please hurry up if he
comments on girls instagrams wow
again
just put that again so you caught him
slacking yeah how did that feel
great
great
what great
talk to me about i feel great what are
you what are you saying no i'm just
saying that this gives you a reason it
gives you an excuse
because he acts like that how do you act
i don't know i'm a good
good
god
so it gives you a reason to act the way
you act
that's all you're disclosing
okay cool okay all right
maya
if you're talking to girl on instagram i
mean social media oh
[ __ ]
so if he's talking to girls on instagram
yeah so if he messages a girl on
instagram again yeah again so he did it
before yeah and you caught him yeah so
you did it back to him yeah
oh
it was just yeah yeah yeah we we
we question
free when i first saw my boyfriend's
blank
i was extremely disappointed
um what does that mean yeah
when i first saw my boyfriend's blank
i was extremely disappointed no okay
did you see that yeah okay i saw you
pointing there you go it's it's up to
you
i don't know how that's what they all
think you know i know get your mind at
the guy but if it's me if you was
disappointed then you can say that as an
actor i was all right now already yeah i
feel like oh yeah you basically just
said it
um penis
no need to be shy about it's been inside
you all right
your toes need to be looking like this
you see these nails that us man got yeah
pink you get go get that manicure and
pediatrics
it's okay only like 12 bills
so what are you saying did he scratch
you in the night
do you wake up with something like that
you know the dog
nails like that
gangrene on them
he looks like he needs a decapitation on
the top just dark nails
dark nails yeah all right cool okay
all right cool
we've heard your answers now let's see
what the guys have got to say all right
men can we have you back please come on
doctors
if we were animals
my boyfriend would be a blank in the
bedroom harms what do you think the
blank was
oh so
would you like it slow
slow
i would say gorilla
i don't know
this geezer rates himself you know
harambee in that isn't my man dead
this giza fully raised himself do you
want to know a fun fact
and this is actual this is an actual
fact
do you know gorillas have extremely
small penises i swear i don't even know
wait how do you know that i don't read
their feelings i know bear animal facts
david ambrose my guy oh man
anyway
the answers are in
so you said
gorilla and you said
and one of yours was right harms
well done
she said that you're slow and pathetic
in the bedroom yeah congratulations i
don't know why you're sitting here why
are you dancing slow strokes like you go
you know what i'm saying
you try to make love yeah i'm making
love i'm not just rags
bro have you seen that man's head bro
that man's head is so horizontal
and they just hang bro their arms are
mad long
like bro that's not a compliment bro
i don't even think they have genitals i
think they're just asexual they're
binary nonbinary because she's finished
herself before he even crawls onto the
bed
babe i'm coming
my mouth is already done like two times
in those days she's already finished
already
and you said gorilla and i'll save a
survey said lion so
yeah but it wasn't a gorilla it was more
of a lion you know what i'm saying the
leader of the pack kind of thing long
hair don't care do you know what i'm
saying question two i said to your
girlfriends
if my boyfriend blanks again i'll be
gone
cheek
straight let's cheats that's all i can
think of
arms
she's always stressing about like
instagram and
liking and all of that like
so if she was dropping love eyes on my
picks you wouldn't mind no that's a bit
mad still but you're allowed to comment
whatever you want on girl's fault but
she's not no she can she can comment she
can comment there's a song it's an old
song i don't know how old you are but it
says when you're out in the club don't
think she's not i just want to leave you
with that whatever you do with that you
do with that
oh we need a var
you know i didn't want to say anything
just to see how well you think i would
judge it and you're correct i did write
var you got it right you did get it
right well done however
you said cheating okay now do you want
to be more specific how did you cheat
same as him really
commenting oh so it's more instagram
based rather than penis vagina base yeah
both
no no no no no it's instagram babies
because i never a man had he wanted it
you know
no i take that back i never physically
cheated
so it has it has to be like you know
once you insert your penis into a female
you can't take that back right i can't
take it bad bro about take it back yeah
no no no no
okay so it's a point each for that round
well done well done guys so for question
three
i said
when i first saw my boyfriend's blank i
was extremely disappointed what did you
think the girl said to them well i'm
nigerian so therefore has to be hiding
in the car
but i'm nigerian zordo shout out him
all i should be violating my feet so
i'll say feet
what's wrong with your feet i don't even
know you need to ask her what color is
your feet the color of my skin
so you said feet
and harms you said hype
i can now confirm that one of yous was
right it wasn't you
yeah congratulations johan your feet are
[ __ ]
and your girlfriend knows it and
i'll decide to well you was
kind of on the right track
you said height
actually it was about the height of your
penis
[Music]
we've done a multiple choice question
for this one
we've asked a few things and we've made
you both write it down and we're gonna
see if your answers were in sync are you
ready if you could describe your
boyfriend's
mom
what would it be
diary of a mad black woman
devil wears prada
or the witch
and you both reveal your answers
wow we love to see him
okay
you're saying that his mom's a mad black
woman is that in a good way in a good
way in a good way
you know like the african mom just mad
oh okay in a good way i can relate to
that story okay yeah
and um the devil wears prada you're
saying the double where's prada okay so
they both get the point
[Applause]
sticking to the theme of movie titles
but this time it's a horror movie if you
was to describe your boyfriend's ex as a
movie title it
the clown
the rat
or
dawn of the dead
okay
you're so happy oh my god ugliness
what was the reasoning
it
it so you're saying that his girlfriend
looked like a clown yeah
so his ex
yeah could you guys reveal the answers
please
wow okay the rat and it's
okay so i think it was the nicest one
but he called his girlfriend
his ex yeah his ex
careful now
they all nearly started a french wall
there didn't you man
in the bedroom my boyfriend would be
gone in 60 seconds
the incredible hulk
or scream
okay oh my goodness so
absolutely as you can see your
girlfriend said scream
and you said incredible hope you just
really rate yourself nah really your
girl thinks you scream like a little
girl i say scream that's not even a
scream no so what would you scream oh
wow
no i thought it was for me
oh
my goodness
don't let him don't listen the only
thing don't look at gas like you okay
don't let him put words into your mouth
and manipulate you
oh yeah and hearts
now you man are getting violated today
you know i said that i said screaming
people are screaming
okay so do you want to elaborate he's
just vocal
no i want you to do the video
or r kelly play songs
trey songz
he's like
on your side
we have four points
team harms
we have five points oh
we lost by one point
just one so guys as you can see these
guys are pathetic losers and we are back
for the final with amanda and leighton
and hans and oyena they're gonna go
head-to-head badly out to see who wins
that cash money and a hundred free
fire away pizzas yes sir
let's scale it we'll see you there
bigws like we only take w's no else
so i feel like
we're ready for the final like we did so
well well
like i said we're born winners but for
you to win you have to lose
so
yeah we lose us today tomorrow will be
winners i feel like it kind of it's
brought us closer
yeah
yeah we're good we don't we don't really
regret anything it was a good experience
we don't do this every day so yeah it's
a good experience surely the captain
that's all i'm going to say
yeah she'll be captain about the whole
um
the whole what
before the show we've been relationship
goals after the show we're definitely
going to be relationship goals
so yeah you like got real competitive
close to the end and
you edged it by one point there's
literally one point between you and the
winner of relationship goals is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you